[음악]
과연네
안녕하세요. 빌자남이 간다. 오늘은
연무장길 메인에 왔는데 제가 메인
건물 옥상에 좀 나와 있어요. 근데
제가이 건물에 왜 왔느냐? 저희가이
건물을 1층에서 팝업 스토어를
[음악]
합니다. 요번 주금토일 진행할
예정인데 혹시 만약에 관심 있는 분들
계시면 방문해 주시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 제가 주소는 댓글에 남겨
드릴테니까 많은 분들 와 주시면은
좋을 거 같고 그리고 구독자라고
얘기를 해 주시면은 제가 좀 특별한
선물을 좀 드릴 예정입니다. 구독자
여러분들도 좀 많이 오시면 좋을 거
같고 우리 회사의 연무장길 전문으로
하시는 분이 계세요. 방명한 이사라고
지금이 건물도 중계했을뿐만 아니라
여기를 그동안 참 많이 팠어요.이
연무장기를 좀 여러분들한테 좀
자세하게 설명을 드릴 예정입니다.
그래서 한번 제가 모셔보고 한번
자세한 얘기 들어 보도록 하겠습니다.
안녕하십니까? 저는 길산남 부동산
중개법인의 박명한 이사라고 하고요.이
건물을 중계했고 내 연무장길에 대해서
조금 지금 이해도가 많이 높은
상황입니다. 엽무장길에 대해서 일단
좀 설명 좀 해 주세요. 어,
연무장길 같은 경우는이 대한민국에서
이렇게 약간 플랫하게 평평하게 한
1.7km 정도 되는 이제이 골목기를
가지고 있거든요. 예전에는 여기가
이제 뭐 공장
지대였었지만 지금은 우리가 누구나 다
아는 플래그십 스토어 또는 뭐 팝업
스토어들이 질비해서 들어오는
곳이고요. 여기 지금 임대료 자체가
대한민국 최고라고 해도네 과언이
아닙니다. 하루당 뭐 평수에 따라
조금 다르겠지만 하루에 1,500만
원까지 받습니다. 그게 한
300평에서 한 500평 조금 이제
유동적이긴 하지만 100만 원 또는
뭐 2천만 원까지도 볼 수가 있고요.
또 그다음에 좀 규모가 작은 열평짜리
그런 이제 팝업 스토어 같은 경우도
하루에 100만 원에서 150만
원까지 진행을 하고 있습니다. 그리고
지금 여기 우리가 현수막을 크게
달았는데 직접 전화를 받고
계시잖아요. 전화 문의는 제가 이제
일상적인 생활을 못 할 정도로 네.
전화가 정말 너무 많이 계속 들어오고
있고 이제 뭐 의류 업체 구두
그다음에 핸드백 그리고 향수 업체
그다음에 화장품 업체 보니까 공통점이
있더라고요.요 다섯 개 다 여성분들이
많이 쓰는 이제 업체들이 정말 전화가
많이 오시고 지금도 한 세 개 업체
정도랑 이제 딜을 조금 보고 있는
상황입니다. 한 23년도 기준으로
지금은 아마 한 몇 배 정도 더
늘었을 것 같은데 여기 유동 인구만
2만 명. 제가 생각했었을 때 지금
주말 같은 경우에는 거의 뭐 한 5만
명까지 이쪽을네 이용을 할 거
같아요. 업체를 얘기해도 될지
모르겠지만 맞힘 의료 업체가 있어요.
거기가 여기 성수동 매장을 다합해서
달에 한 10억 정도 매출이 나오는
걸로 알고 있습니다. 거의 달에
10억이면 연매출 한 100억 넘는
거 맞습니다. 그래서 실제로 이제
판매 매출이다 보니까 뭐 노출 홍보
효과도 있을 거고 실제로 판매도
되니까 여기를 선택하시게 되는 것
같습니다. 사실 여기 뭐 어 젠틀
몬스터부터 그다음에 무신사 그다음에
뭐 크래프톤이라는 뭐 대기업들 이외에
그 아래에 있는 업세들까지 여기
건물을 매입을 정말 많이 하고
있고요. 실제로도 거기서 사무실로
운영을 하다 보니까 이제 뭐 다른
지역들처럼 여기가 쭉 빠져나가기는
개인적인 생각이지만 쉽진 않다.
그래서 지금이 어 그냥 평일
화요일네 1시 반이거든요. 사실 지금
이제 보시면은 외국인들이 지금 한
80% 이상 어 돌아다니고 있고요.
근데이 외국인 분들이 뭐 실제로 이제
소비도 하지만 여기 볼꼬리가 너무
많습니다. 네. 여기가 한 1. 6,
7km 정도 되는 라인부터 팝업부터
그다음에 향수 그다음에 뭐 화장품
그다음에 뭐 의류까지 다 여기서 이제
한 번에 어 소비 활동이 가능하기
때문에 와서도 건물들을 이제 너무
예쁘게 잘 지어 놨거든요. 보면서 좀
놀랍습니다. 이게 화요일 날 그냥
1시 반 일하는 상권이라는게 사실
지금 대한민국 어딜 가더라도 뭐 아마
비교할게 있으면은 뭐 도상공원 정도
도산공원보다는 지금 여기에 유동인 건
훨씬 더 많은 거 같아요. 그러니까
약간 비결한 명동일 것 같네
맞습니다.
이거 보니까 여기는 주택이었던 거
같네요. 네. 기존에는 여기 이제
주택으로 사용되고 있다가 그 용도
변경을 하고 지금은 이제 근생 시설로
되어 있고요. 이제 연모장길 상권
특성상 뭐 3층이나 4층을 엄청나게
이제 사용하실 분들은 많이 없을 거
같아요. 제가 여기 이제 들어오실
분들한테 좀 드릴 만한 메리트라고
하면은 유일하게이 건물에 그 중계기가
달려 있습니다.요 금방에서는 가장
높은 건물이 되거든요.
네네층까지 바깥에다가 할 수
있거든요. 예쁘게 자기 브랜드
현수막을 붙여 놓으면 좋을 것 같고
3차층 같은 경우에는 뭐 직원들 이제
뭐 휴계소라던가 아니면 실제 사무실로
쓰고 그다음에 1층부터 2층까지는네
리테일 업장으로 사용하시는게 가장
좋을 것 같습니다. 아 그래도 증고가
높네요. 지금 여기가 지금 3층이고
원래는 네, 의류 업체에서 네.
사무실로 사용을 하고 있었습니다.
아, 그래서 저희가 1층에 팝업하는
공간에 왔는데 여기는 어떤
공간이었어요? 원래 예전에는 건물주가
여기서 지금은 상상도 할 수 없지만
그 석유를 파셨습니다. 네. 석유를
파시던 공간이 당시는 그죠? 네,
맞습니다. 공장 단지라던가 그런게
굉장히 많았어서 그랬던 공간이 지금
어떻게 보면은 뭐 가장 메인 자리로
예, 바뀌게 됐고요.이
벽도 네, 철거가 가능합니다. 지금은
이제 임차인이 들어가져 있고요.
요것까지 다 철거해서 만약에 쓰게
된다 그러면은 한 20평이 조금 넘는
1층 공간을 확보할 수가 있을 것
같고요. 어, 저도 이제요 창은 이제
전에 쓰던 이제 임차인 분들이 남기고
간 것인데요 창을 조금 더 뭐 크게
아니면 조금 더 앞으로 빼서 공간
확보를 할 수가 있을 것 같습니다.
사실 지금 뭐 바닥이라든가 그런 거
보면은 아직 막 공사 중이고 난리도
아닌데 6월 달부터 8월 달 또는
이제 뭐 8월 달부터 뭐 11월
달까지는 뭐 믿으실지
모르겠지만네 그 입점 제한은 거의 다
끝났다고 보시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
벌써요?네
벌써요? 네. 네. 정말로는 이제 좀
골라서 이렇게 인차인을 어 할 수
있다는게 지금이 대한민국에서 좀
가능한한 일인 건지 굉장히 좀
신기합니다. 그래서 만약에 이제 뭐
임대 문이라던가 그런 거는 아마 뭐
8월 달
이후로 연락을 주셔야지 그나마 좀
협의가 가능할 것 같습니다. 건물은
다 좀 둘러봤고 일단 요번 주에
파버스터가 열리고 저희가 나중에
임대까지 마친 다음에 또 촬영하면
좋을 거 같아요. 그때 한번 어떤
인차인을 맞추는지도 한번 촬영을 해
보도록 하겠습니다. 일단 오늘 좀
어떠셨어요? 좀 도움이 많이 좀
됐으면은 좋겠다라고 생각을 하는데
일단 그 성수동에 대해서 마지막으로
좀 간략히 정리를 해 드리면은
결국에는 성수동이 이제 팔리는 이유가
수익률
왜냐면은 이렇게 유동 인구가 많고
사람들이 많으니까 기업들이 찾고
그다음에 업체들이 찾고 그다음에 돈을
오히려 더 지불하겠다라는 좀 정말 뭐
기한 현상이 발생되는 곳이 성수동이고
그다음에 수익률이 나오다 보니까 네.
쪽에 되게 좀 유명했던 건물인데 저게
이제 평당 3억에 맞아요. 그 거래가
됐거든요. 그래서 만약에 저 건물만
하더라도 수익률이 명도를 하면은
어마어마하게 나올 거다. 이게
정확하게 퍼센테이지를 말하기엔 좀
곤란하지만 우리가 그동안 봤던 그
수익률은 아니죠. 제일 맞습니다.
그죠. 네. 어마어마한
수익률이더라고요. 네. 그래서 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하겠습니다. 여러분
감사합니다.